what do you make of the uh for time for
most of the time the nkvd was about the
head of uh and KVD
ente pavlovich barrier now barrier yeah
I have a I have a death warrant signed
by him hanging in my kitchen that I uh
um acquired
um he was one of the most evil people
who ever lived
uh the thing that Americans don't
appreciate is how clever some of the
sadism
is so there was one uh actress I think
he took her back to his house and he
asked her he tried to get her to sleep
with him then he promised her that if
she did her father and either her
husband or her grandfather and which one
it was it's going to be released from
jail well they're already dead at that
point he had them executed
um they're still finding the bodies of
the women he murdered uh in the grounds
of his daughter it's an embassy now and
the thing is Stalin knew because at one
point Stalin there's a picture of
Stalin's daughter in his lap you know
and she was at his house one day and
Stalin calls up he goes get out of there
immediately so he like a good bureaucrat
he had a he kept a list of all of his
sexual partners it's still uh um sealed
but both him and his bodyguard had this
list so just to clarify yeah he headed
the operation that did this whole giant
mechanism of forced confessions yes he
was part of expanding the gulag so he
was in the head of the Glocks but he was
part of this giant and his famous quote
was show me the man and I'll show you
the crime yeah
but on top of that what you're
describing is he was also related or not
was also just a mass rapist yes and
there's some dispute by whether he went
after kids with his rapes but there's
plenty of adults women that were uh
targets for this there was also another
little joke about him about how Stalin
is looking for his pipe and he can't
find didn't he calls barrier and he's
like okay I can't find this pipe and in
the afternoon he calls Barry again he's
like oh I found the pipe he goes but but
comrade Stalin we've got four people to
confess to stealth already so you have
to laugh but then you think about the
nature of how it operates it well also
the fact that this kind of person was
allowed to run
I mean I I suppose
um it's all different kinds of evil and
rape was just a part of the story
his own personal
um willingness to uh
oversee torture and commit torture
himself
and rape but it's also what happens when
you're in a country where it has no
rights of any kind
and by the way I should mention that
people should get your book and audio
what is your audiobook coming up it's in
a couple weeks so I'll be out shortly
yeah uh you gave me the great honor of
uh voicing this man that's for the promo
yeah for the promo yeah excellent I
appreciate that
for a moment I actually
it was really difficult really yeah it
was just a sentence I understand I
understand
I uh because it takes you to that place
oh yeah because he told her scream if
you want doesn't matter yeah and he was
right like that's the thing he wasn't
bluffing he could scream these women
could scream their head off no one's
gonna come help him he would drive
around Moscow at night in his limo
looking for victims but somehow me
saying those words was tough I'm sure is
uh uh stuff
because this is where we came from do
you know what I mean this isn't just
like some kind of uh Tolkien villain
but it also was tough because I could
see myself being somewhere in that
machine somewhere like somehow that put
me right there
like
any like they're
any Cog in that machine is committing
evil yes
that's the dark thing
um
I think the the hot the the higher you
are to the top the closer you are to the
top the more
ability you have to stop it
but the less the more freedom you have
to stop it I suppose
um to a point yeah
but like the little things
so barrier had the freedom to commit
rape
or not to
and so he chooses to
sort of increase the amount of evil he's
putting out into the world but then you
have to counterbalance that as as dark
as this calculus is after Stalin dies
like that week they start making the
gulag shrink they start pulling back on
the concentrate the labor camps
so I mean
so that is a big Plus in his side like
you start liberating having this Mass
amnesty and freeing people from uh work
camps that that's not minor things so
it's crazy like it's like I I'm not I'm
not saying Peter right I don't I I don't
know I'm not saying he's a good person
but it's kind of insane that someone can
do things that everyone listening to
this would regard as pure evil and at
the same time this guy also when the
time came saved tens of thousands of
lives so in some sense Stalin is the
kind of cancer that permeates all yes
all the Soviet minds and once it's gone
you almost like wake up wait a minute
what the [ __ ] was I a part of and
Khrushchev in it was a 56 when he gave
his secret speech uh you know behind
closed doors and he's just like all this
criticism Aston was true this is
complete I want marxistence you know he
tried to salvage the system this is not
what Marxism is about we can't have a
personality cult uh you know Stalin
killed all these top generals and when
Hitler turned to betrayed The Pact and
invaded Stalin didn't believe his buddy
Hitler was going to do this and as a
result of this we lost a lot of
territory in lives this is not a
military genius this was Stalin being an
idiot or an a [ __ ] whatever you so
whatever term we want to be so you know
yeah there but the thing is Khrushchev
also was a butcher you know he had a lot
of blood in his hands you don't become
you know the textile seat without having
overlooked a lot of uh murder and Chaos
so I it's such a um that's why it's
called subtitled books the tale of Good
and Evil there's so much malevolence to
go around